hi I'm Simon Coughlin Hanson from IBM
cloud and today we're here to talk about
IBM cloud for VMware solutions this is
the most secure enterprise grade cloud
for VMware at scale so let's break down
what does this mean the security
leadership enterprise grade and the
VMware expertise at scale starting with
the security leadership IBM provides the
highest form of encryption for data at
rest and data and motion with FIPS 140 -
2 level 4 based encryption ensuring that
your data where it resides and while
it's moving around within your
organization is using the highest form
of encryption available out in the
market today we also provide in our
security role based access control
allowing different parts of your
organization to interact with the data
maintaining the compliance the security
and the visibility to the different
parts of the business and ensuring the
wrong people don't get access to the
wrong types of data furthermore we can
comply with data sovereignty regulations
ensure we provide geofencing for your
workloads ensuring data doesn't
necessarily cross the relevant borders
as we find this becomes more and more
easily achievable in this card and this
virtual based world we want to ensure
that this sovereignty remains intact
also providing compliance and regulatory
control through config management and
managing the configuration drift through
our wide variety of partners we've
brought all these different security
solutions together all based on the
real-time advice and guidance provided
from our highly regulated and security
conscious clients so let's explore
enterprise-grade and what does that mean
so what we've done is we've utilized and
codified IBM's experience of managing
for over a decade
these 850,000 based VMware workloads for
all our enterprise clients across the
world and these consist of banking
government and things in the financial
sector insurance retail and all the
other industry sectors and the ability
to take all that experience codify it
and creating an automated way of
deploying these solutions out there the
automation that we have provided not
only brings a rapid provisioning and a
rapid uptime to provide these solutions
and these platforms but it has ancillary
benefits downstream by making these
solutions much easier to support and
much easier for all the third parties
that we have out there to integrate
their solutions and integrate their
products onto this overall platform the
other thing with enterprise-grade is we
have the largest footprint of the
solution available with the solution
available in over 35 data centers
globally we also have the flexibility
and this is what the final factor of
enterprise-grade the flexibility of
options and the flexibility of choice
with the myriad of options that you can
choose and what I mean by that is we
have a number of different storage
options as we found out by direct
lessons learned from the enterprise is
most enterprises are not going to choose
just one or two different storage
options so taking that lessons learnt
you have a myriad of choice with
Software Defined back storage with
endurance based storage and with object
storage for long term data archiving and
retrieval all these lessons learnt have
been brought together along with the
partners and our broad partner ecosystem
to bring together what we believe is a
truly enterprise grade and enterprise
ready solution which has been tested
validated and verified by many of the
enterprises out there today VMware
expertise a global scale let's dive into
that for a second or two with the
largest manager of workloads out there
with 850 thousand VMs under management
we've migrated over a hundred thousand
workloads from on-premise into the cloud
and ensuring and helping our clients out
there with their data transformation we
have over the decades worth of
experience
in managing these workloads providing
these solutions across various industry
verticals so with these three things it
all makes it out to be why we're unique
in the market with our VMware solutions
thank you for watching this video today
and please feel free to leave any
comments down below if you like this
content please like and subscribe to
future videos around this and many other
subjects on IBM cloud